chris took me and there's a sulfur bath
in one of them it was horrible how was
that it was a talk
it was like yeah i come up with the ph
was it was like one it was uh
two but it was a it was a p it was a ph
of two it's like how people dissolve
people they've murdered yeah so it isn't
ph of two
dangerous it wasn't it was pretty high
it was like two or something not really
something like that that's basically
acid can we google what ph is you can
but
ph2 is like very dangerous especially
especially to bathe
you dude you get in it and you get out
your skin is all red
and my it kind of makes your skin
tingling yeah yeah you feel like i was
saying to god
why is this a thing yes
realize because i think it said only
five minutes but me and chris were in
there for like 30 minutes
we came out and like when you when you
do it your skin you
can't yeah two is one of the most acidic
ph's you can do one
at the end of the [ __ ] scale works
it's zero to seven gone
i understand the numeric scale but no
google the onsen
google onsen ph levels
i i can read from zero to fourteen
that's not the same
that would just handle like a limit
[Laughter]
it's really cool because like the snow
is falling all around you it's outside
and
you go out and you yeah you're just like
you're stinging your whole body yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it's just like bathed
in acid of course it would have yeah
right
yeah yeah ps2 is legit yeah
yeah it was told you was it two h2
because when i was waiting for chris
when i was waiting for chris because
every single onsen has a sign outside of
it telling you all the chemical makeup
and the ph
and i saw it was like 2.1 and i was like
[ __ ] hell
that's if you've been in there like
come out just bones it's like a mr beast
video
it was it survived the acid bar i'll
give you ten thousand dollars it felt
really good though when you
when you got out because you just felt
as clean as you've ever been well
we did it you [ __ ] sanitize your
entire skin
it's not fun it's not good i'm pretty
sure that's how people like remove
tattoos
and all these skin peels just going like
that yeah that's so horrible
it was horrible i highly recommend
trying i couldn't like sleep that night
[ __ ] off don't take our word don't take
it don't listen to cause
i think i'd rather bathe in ethanol
bathing hand sanitizer i think that's
that's safer but this is more fun
massive i did not sleep that night could
you imagine if you like accidentally
drank the water
oh well actually you can't really i
don't think you can drink the water at
the hotel because
it's like this hotel stunk like do you
remember how bad it is just smell it the
whole
defaults yeah because the whole because
it's because it's all like built on
sulfur right so this is because you're
bathing in a volcano
so you like you're saying in this room
and you cannot stop smelling
rotten eggs and farts like the whole
time i was like chris this chris or just
i can't [ __ ] tell it says chris was
like ripping a fat one like every five
minutes
have you guys ever been in a bureau
what's that electrical
i have yeah no i haven't passed an
electric current through the walls it's
like yeah
and i didn't know what it was it's
horrible so i walked into this bath once
walked through i was like why are my
legs tingling am i having a heart attack
why
and then i i saw the kanji for
electricity and bath and i was like [ __ ]
why are you having a laugh and they yeah
they they run a low voltage current
through them
you are kidding me yeah it's the same
feeling as the sulfuric water basically
it feels like acid but oh is that it's
kind of scary someone just accidentally
things that shouldn't be mixed is like
electricity and water i'm pretty sure we
learned that when we were like
three like it's like someone dropping
like a little toaster
when i was very young and again i didn't
know it either what it was so the moment
i stepped in i was like
mommy i'm dying what's happening why
can't i notice
it was acid acid bath with electricity
thousand dollar challenge would stand at
the longest thousand dollars that's not
worth a thousand dollars
does like japan have health and safety
regulations
you can go i don't think so it goes out
to ph it's two it's safe
it's safe i'm just wondering imagine
like trying to pitch this idea in the uk
all right so all right we're gonna do
like a special bath it's gonna
people can bathe in acid i wanna hear me
out you can drop a toaster but you won't
die